do you have a system for consistently
generating viral content no because
spiral content by nature is viral and
uncontrollable I have a system to
produce consistent content with the hope
of it being viral the only people sit
around all day trying to figure out how
to make something viral that's against
the definition of viral make good
content and then have your moments in
time nobody on Earth can predict
virality some of the things that work on
my Tick Tock and Instagram and YouTube
shorts things that I could never have
imagined on the flip side things that
I'm positive when I post them that
they're gonna hit don't and I'm a human
being who's been doing this for 15 years
every day and I've been successful and
yet I am often wrong of the tone and
temperament of the moment of my audience
how agencies sit in Ivory Towers in
boardrooms and think they know is
audacious at best and ludicrous at worst
everybody wants viral but what actually
works is consistent content